Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, on va avoir besoin...
De ça.
Et ce n'est pas pour vous parler
de petites bestioles, mais de géographie,
des cinq plus petits pays du monde.
Ils sont minuscules,
mais malgré leur taille,
vous allez le voir,
on ne peut pas les louper.
On commence ce classement par le cinquième
plus petit pays du monde.
Il s'agit de...
Saint-Marin.
À ne pas confondre
avec Saint-Martin, une île des Antilles.
Saint-Marin, donc, ou San Marino,
est un micro-État indépendant,
enclavé dans la botte italienne.
Au nord, dans la chaîne des Apennins,
pas très loin de la mer Adriatique.
Quand je vous dis que c'est petit,
ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit.
Cet état s'étend sur 61,2
kilomètres carrés.
Pour vous donner une idée,
il est à peine plus grand
que la ville de Montpellier
et un peu plus petit que celle de Nantes.
Saint-Marin est dominé
par le mont Titan, sur lequel se dressent
trois tours
qui ont fait la réputation du site.
Elles assuraient autrefois sa défense.
Selon la légende,
ce petit pays doit son nom
à un tailleur de pierre chrétien
appelé... Marin.
En l'an 301, fuyant
les persécutions de l'empereur Dioclétien,
il s'installe sur le mont Titan.
Très vite, d'autres chrétiens
le rejoignent et fondent ici
une communauté religieuse.
Saint-Marin est surtout connue
pour être l'une
des plus anciennes républiques du monde !
Elle a été proclamée dès le XIIIᵉ siècle
et son système constitutionnel actuel
daterait de l'année 1600.
Aujourd'hui,
le micro-état compte une population
d'à peine 34000 personnes.
C'est l'équivalent de la ville d'Auxerre.
Et jusqu'à la crise financière de 2008,
c'était l'un des pays
les plus riches au monde par habitant.
Direction maintenant le Pacifique Sud,
à l'est de l'Australie pour découvrir notre quatrième
plus petit pays du monde.
Allez,
il faut zoomer sur la carte, encore un peu,
un petit peu plus.
Et voici Tuvalu.
Il s'agit d'un archipel
composé de 9 atolls.
Au total, ces îles coralliennes
s'étendent sur seulement 26 kilomètres
carrés !
À titre de comparaison,
c'est la superficie
d'une ville comme Orléans.
Chacune a son petit nom en Tuvaluan,
la langue locale polynésienne.
Et comme j'aime les défis,
je vais essayer de toutes vous les citer.
Alors il y a la Nanumea
Nanumaga, Niutao
Nui, Niulakita,
Nukufetau, Nukulaelae,
Vaitupu, et...
Funafuti, la capitale.
Ancien territoire colonisé
par les Britanniques, Tuvalu accède
à son indépendance en 1978,
mais il se maintient dans le Commonwealth.
Formellement, son chef d'État reste
donc la reine Elisabeth II.
Loin de la pluie londonienne,
Tuvalu est un petit paradis terrestre,
avec des plages de sable blanc,
des eaux turquoises
et une végétation luxuriante.
Malheureusement, l'archipel
est menacé par la montée des eaux
due au réchauffement climatique.
Selon les scientifiques,
depuis 1993, le niveau de l'océan à Tuvalu
monte de plus de cinq millimètres
tous les ans.
C'est plus rapide que la moyenne mondiale,
qui s'établit à 3,5 mm par an.
Cette montée des eaux
accélère l'érosion des côtes et menace
de faire disparaître totalement
ce petit pays.
Allez, on prend nos pagaies
et on rame en direction
du troisième
plus petit pays du monde, Nauru.
Bon, d'accord, j'exagère un peu.
Nauru est situé à 1 400 kilomètres de Tuvalu,
dans l'hémisphère sud,
juste en dessous de l'équateur.
D'ailleurs, son drapeau coupé
en deux par une ligne transversale
sous laquelle se trouve
une étoile, illustre très bien
cette situation géographique !
Au fil des ans,
la vie de ses habitants a été influencée
par les différentes présences étrangères
sur l'île.
Colonisé par les Britanniques en 1798,
Nauru est ensuite passé aux mains
des Allemands.
A la fin du XIXᵉ siècle,
ces derniers y découvrent
d'énormes gisements de phosphate,
une substance minérale
utilisée comme fertilisant,
et qui entre aussi
dans la fabrication des explosifs.
Après un passage
sous le contrôle de l'Australie,
Nauru accède enfin à son indépendance
en 1968.
Grâce à l'extraction du phosphate,
les Nauruans s'enrichissent
et accèdent à un niveau de vie élevé
dans les années 70.
Très élevé même pour certains.
Il devient le pays possédant
le plus haut PIB
par habitant du monde,
trois fois plus élevé que celui d'un
habitant des Etats-Unis à l'époque.
Mais ça ne dure pas.
Dans les années
1990,
les gisements de phosphate s'épuisent
et l'économie de l'île s'effondre.
Aujourd'hui, le taux de chômage du pays
atteint 90% de sa population active !
L'abondance a également eu des effets
pervers
sur la santé de la population :
Nauru est en effet connu
pour avoir le taux d'obésité
le plus élevé au monde : 61%
des adultes sont affectés.
Autrefois petit paradis
naturel, Nauru est devenu l'un des pays
les moins visités au monde.
Revenons sous nos latitudes
pour une visite du deuxième
plus petit état du monde.
Top !
Je suis
un rocher situé sur la Côte d'Azur.
Je suis une principauté connu pour mes
casinos et mon Grand Prix de Formule 1.
Je suis... je suis ? Vous l'avez deviné,
Monaco !
Ville-État située en bord de Méditerranée,
la principauté s'étend sur une superficie
de 2,02 kilomètres carrés.
C'est moins que Central Park à New York !
Forteresse stratégique au Moyen Âge,
le territoire était à l'origine
aux mains de la République
de Gênes.
En 1297,
Monaco devient la propriété du génois
François Grimaldi.
C'est le début de la longue
lignée de princes
qui se succéderont jusqu'à Albert II,
sans jamais être roi.
Et si Monaco n'est pas un royaume,
c'est aussi un peu en raison de sa taille.
Tout petit État,
le Rocher a besoin
que ses voisins acceptent son statut
si particulier.
La principauté a d'ailleurs signé en 1918
un traité avec la France qui lui accorde
une forme de protection.
Et ceci à certaines conditions,
en particulier,
si la dynastie des Grimaldi
venait à s'éteindre,
Le territoire monégasque
intégrerait la France.
Monaco bat tous les records :
c'est le pays
le plus densément peuplé au monde
avec une population de plus de 39000
résidents.
Le Rocher compte environ
19000 habitants au kilomètre carré.
À titre de comparaison, en France,
on est en moyenne
à 119 habitants par kilomètre carré.
Monaco est aussi l'État qui compte
la plus grande
proportion de millionnaires
et de milliardaires.
Bref, le Rocher est une sorte
de pierre précieuse.
Pour terminer,
cette vidéo, on reste en Europe.
Un peu plus au sud. Retour en Italie.
Le plus petit État du monde
est enclavé dans la ville de Rome,
le Vatican.
44 hectares, c'est grosso modo
20 fois plus petit
que le domaine du château de Versailles.
Le siège de l'Église catholique est devenu
indépendant le 11 février 1929.
C'est le seul État au monde
où l'une
des langues officielles est le latin.
On y parle aussi l'italien, l'allemand
et le français pour la diplomatie !
D'ailleurs,
pour les organisations internationales,
la résidence du pape est
officiellement un État francophone.
Il faut que je fasse
attention à ce que je dis.
En fait, environ
la moitié de la population du Saint-Siège
vit en dehors de la cité du Vatican,
occupant des fonctions diplomatiques
dans le monde entier.
En tout, le Vatican compte à peine
plus de 800 citoyens,
faisant aussi de lui le pays
le moins peuplé du monde.
Peu d'habitants, mais qui savent vivre !
Le Vatican est le pays
où l'on consomme le plus de vin
par habitant :
74 litres par an
et par personne, soit 99 bouteilles.
Et pas que du vin de messe.
On en a d'ailleurs
fait un post sur notre compte Instagram.
N'hésitez pas à le consulter.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Les habitants du Vatican
sont pour la plupart des ecclésiastiques
et des gardes suisses.
Il y en a 135.
Chargés de la sécurité du pape,
ces gardes constituent d'ailleurs
l'une des plus petites
et des plus anciennes armées du monde.
Décidément.
Mais ne vous fiez pas à cette litanie
de petits chiffres associés au Vatican :
c'est un pays très riche !
La cité-état abrite
la basilique Saint-Pierre,
la plus grande église au monde,
ainsi que certaines des œuvres d'art
les plus célèbres de la Renaissance,
comme la Pietà,
une statue en marbre de Michel-Ange
et la création d'Adam
qu'il a peint sur le plafond de la chapelle
Sixtine !
Evidemment,
ça fait lever les yeux au ciel.
Et voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout,
c'est le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne !
J'espère d'ailleurs
que vous l'avez appréciée.
N'hésitez
pas à mettre un pouce bleu en l'air
et à me proposer des sujets
pour les prochaines vidéos.
Et si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
abonnez-vous !
Comme ça, je pourrais peut-être fonder
un nouveau royaume.
Le JamyLand !